oh là là ils veulent leur dose de
frissons trois histoires d'horreur trois
histoires vraies un peu flippante vécue
par des gens heureusement pas nous avec
différentes mécaniques
aujourd'hui on aura une histoire courte
puis une histoire très longue cuillère
eu une histoire courte cette histoire
très longue elle est très longue parce
qu'elle traite d'un truc on n'a jamais
traité dans l'est serait de rares donc
voilà même si c'est long c'est pas grave
ça vaut le coup d'en parler je pense
bref comment sont d'abord avec une
première histoire du coup plutôt courte
c'est l'histoire de dames d'albi avec sa
femme dans une maison de deux étages
accessible via deux entrées une plutôt
classique sur le devant de la maison là
où se trouve aussi un porche donc très
classique aux us et une autre sur le
côté de la maison qui donne sur la
buanderie dane et sa femme ont un chat
c'est peut-être pour ça que j'ai choisi
cette histoire peut-être le soir de
l'incident dan est seul chez lui et
décide d'accorder une petite sortie à
son chien aux alentours de minuit il
accroche donc à la longe qui est
accroché à l'autre bout aux porsche
c'est un truc routinier souvent dans la
semaine il fait ça il explique que son
chien effet c'est petit pipi et
généralement après quelques minutes il
revient il veut retourner dans la maison
ce soir là d'année en train de ranger sa
vaisselle lorsqu'il entend son chien
gratter à la porte danis dirige donc
vers la porte pour l'ouvrir et pour que
son chien puisse le rejoindre à
l'intérieur sauf que dalle
il a regardé beaucoup trop de films
effrayant et peut-être même de ce raid
horreur du coup il a un réflexe qui est
très bon c'est que à chaque fois que ça
sonne à la porte
à chaque fois que ça gratte ou peu
importe même s'il attend des amis ou
quoi que ce soit dan il regarde toujours
dans l'oeil de la porte pour être sûr
que c'est bien la personne qui devait
lui rendre visite qui est là ce soir là
dan regarde par réflexe à travers l'oeil
de la porte
et surprise ce n'est pas son chien il ya
un homme debout immobile qui fixe
attentivement la poignée de la porte de
dames toutes les faux il a regardé à
travers l'oeil
il pensait que cette situation dans
laquelle il se trouve à ce moment-là
n'arriverait jamais et puis là dan et
l'entente un autre scratch contre la
porte encore plus fort que le précédent
et son second scratch c'est l'homme qui
est de l'autre côté de la porte qui
vient de le faire en grattant avec ses
ongles contre la porte
à partir de là dan cours vers son
portable et il appelle sa femme pour lui
expliquer ce qui se passe sa femme est
confuse elle comprend pas trop il
explique dan que c'est probablement
parce qu'il lui a raconté hyper mal la
chose parce qu'il était en panique
quoi qu'il en soit sa femme lui dit de
pas bouger de faire gaffe à ce que les
portes soient bien fermé et qu'elle
rentre immédiatement le rejoindre dame
raccroche et se rend compte d'un truc
pas ouf c'est que son chien est toujours
dehors d'un décide alors de retourner
vers sa porte d'entrée en faisant le
moins
bruit possible et de regarder une
nouvelle fois à travers l'oeil de la
porte et le mec est toujours là il n'a
pas bougé d'un poil et il est toujours
en train de fixer la poignée de la porte
d'un décide alors de rejoindre la
seconde entrée de sa maison sur la
pointe des pieds a qu'à la porte de la
buanderie il veut tout simplement faire
rentrer son chien dans la maison pour
qu'il ne puisse rien lui arriver étant
donné qu'il ya un inconnu qui est figé
sur son palier depuis trois minutes ils
en trouvent alors la porte de la
buanderie dans le plus grand des
silences jette un coup d'oeil et son
chien n'est pas là malheureusement pour
dan ce côté là de la maison est
recouvert de graviers et il sait que y'a
aucun moyen qui sortent de la maison
sans faire du bruit et sans que
l'inconnu s'en aperçoive il décide donc
de refermer la porte de la buanderie à
claix et de retourner à la porte
principale de sa maison pour voir si
l'inconnu est toujours là et cet inconnu
est toujours là debout sur son palier à
fixer des yeux la poignée de la porte
dany veut avoir une trace de ce à quoi
ressemble et ce gars du coup il va
sortir son téléphone portable de la
poche et essayer de prendre en photo le
mec à travers l'oeil de la porte très
bons réflexes
malheureusement le téléphone de dan
n'arrive pas à focus qu'il ya de l'autre
côté de la vitre de l'oeil et la photo
et tout flou et on voit juste une
silhouette mais on voit pas du tout le
visage de la personne
elle est totalement méconnaissable dan
pas sans suite a appelé la police et
puis se dit que ça n'a pas trop de sens
puisque en fait il ya juste un gars qui
est debout sur son palier et jusqu'à
présent il a rien fait de mal donc il
dit que les flics vont pas le prendre au
sérieux et ça sert à rien de les appeler
quelques secondes plus tard cet inconnu
regarde lui aussi à travers l'oeil de la
porte et il se met à sourire comme s'il
savait que dan se trouvait de l'autre
côté de celle ci et qu'il était en train
d'observer ce moment et dure quelques
secondes et ça y est l'inconnu arrête de
sourires se retourne et descendent la
rue d'alleray sur ses gardes et s'attend
même à ce que le gars en fait et fait
une feinte et que d'un coup il se
retourne et court vers la porte et là
martèle des heureusement sais pas ce qui
se passe le gars est parti pour de vrai
et quelques minutes plus tard il ya la
femme de dan qui arrivent et qui lui dit
méthane appelle la police tu as tu fais
quoi
il a peut-être rien fait pour le moment
mais on sait pas ce qu'il allait faire
il est pas là pour offrir des bons mots
[ __ ] il apte et les mauvaises
intentions il appelle donc la police et
surtout ils partent à la recherche de
leur chien qui je vous rappelle est
toujours dehors et malheureusement le
mec qui était sur le palier a bel et
bien coupé la longe auquel le chien de
dan était attaché dan imagine le pire il
imagine peut-être que le gars pour se
venger d'avoir raté son intrusion chez
lui est parti avec son chien et
heureusement ils le retrouvent dans le
jardin d'un voisin et c'était
probablement la meilleure sortie de sa
vie à ce chien ils ont eu plus tard des
nouvelles de la police et malgré
plusieurs patrouilles dans le coin ils
ont
personne de blizzard dehors et dane et
sa femme ont emménagé pour d'autres
raisons qui n'ont rien à voir avec ça
trois ans plus tard mais dan s'en
souvient et ça l'a bien marquer parce
que comme plein d'autres genres dans
toutes ces histoires il s'est dit mais
il voulait quoi ce gars qu'est ce qu'il
allait faire
bref moral quand quelqu'un toc ou sonne
même si vous attendez quelqu'un on
regarde dans l'oeil de la porte n'est ce
pas messieurs dames
il est temps de raconter la deuxième
histoire elle est longue mais elle est
incroyable je trouve
laissez moi vous raconter l'histoire de
mire mira à 27 ans au moment où elle
raconte son histoire
mais l'histoire a eu lieu dix ans avant
qu elle en avait 17 mai ravi aux états
unis et à cette époque elle s'apprête à
rentrer à l'université
c'est un moment qu'elle attendait elle
était impatiente elle a vu ça comme un
nouveau départ pascal explique qu'au
lycée ça s'est plutôt mal passé pour
elle puisqu'elle s'est fait harceler
elle justifie ses mauvaises expériences
au lycée par le fait qu'elle a une
personnalité assez introverti et qu'elle
est assez maladroite ce à quoi on envie
de lui dire bah non ça ne justifie rien
tu as le droit d'être introverti et
maladroite et c'est pas pour autant que
les gens de droite heures seul est en
revanche elle pense que c'est pour ça
qu'elle n'a toujours pas eu de copains à
ce moment là de sa vie bref un soir il
est tard elle en train de travailler sur
un devoir dans sa chambre et un inconnu
la joute sur msn
je précise au cas où il y en a qui ne
savent pas ce que ça msn c'est pour
parler à tes potes en ligne mira ne
connaît pas le nom et prénom que ya dans
l'adresse mail de la demande qu'elle
reçoit elle ne sait pas qui est cette
personne qui veulent ajouter en ami en
revanche dans l'adresse mail il y a un
nom indien émirats est en elle-même
indienne elle est intriguée elle accepte
la demande pour les besoins de
l'histoire ce garçon mira elle va
l'appeler ken ce soir là elle commence
alors à discuter avec lui et bien
entendu et lui demande comment il a
obtenu son adresse msn et ken esquive
gracieusement la question au fil de la
discussion n'ira apprend que kane est un
poil plus âgé qu'elle et qui vit dans la
même ville qu'elle n'a pas de photo de
profil sur msn et demande à maera s'il
peut faire une conversation vidéo ou
désactive la webcam dans un premier
temps mira refuse
et puisqu'elle réussit à la convaincre
d'une manière ou d'une autre et elle
cède et surprise elle est soulagée
il est dans sa chambre rien d'anormal
rien de bizarre tout va bien je sais que
vous le trouvez chelou ken mais attendez
n'y a rien de bizarre de ou françois à
partir de l'américaine vont continuer de
se parler sur msn tous les jours pendant
plusieurs semaines ils vont même se
mettre à parler par sms et vont même
commencé à s'appeler au téléphone
régulièrement émirats va commencer à
avoir des sentiments pour ksm un jour il
arrive à trouver une date et une heure
où ils sont tous les deux disponibles et
il organise un déjeuner canal permis
donc il propose amira d'aller la
chercher directement à l'université et
ensuite de l'emmener dans
un restaurant végétarien locale que mira
connaissait déjà qui est apparemment un
très bon spot mira accepte et elle
explique que bêtement elles n'a dit à
personne ni ses amis ni sa famille où
elle allait et avec qui parce qu'elle
était gêné le jour j arrive mira sort de
l'université et une voiture arrive le
conducteur baisse la vitre
le visage de cannes apparaît mirail
soulagé c'est pas quelqu'un d'autre ait
pas de plusieurs personnes dans la
voiture il ya jusqu'à heineken fait
signe à mira de rentrer dans la voiture
elle s'assoit sur le siège passager
avant est aussitôt elle ferme la porte
qu'elle met la main sur sa cuisse
mira immédiatement éloigne sa jambe et
elle lance tout de suite un autre sujet
pour réduire le malaise et lui demande
s'il sait où se trouve le restaurant
parce qu'elle lcl peu le guider et donc
elle se dit il est peut-être juste très
nerveux où il est peut-être comme moi
très maladroit c'est pas grave tout va
bien elle laisse couler alors que
clairement ce n'est pas normal ken prend
la bretelle et s'engage sur l'autoroute
mira comprend pas puisqu'elle sait où
ils restaurent et normalement pour y
aller tu n'as pas du tout à prendre
l'autoroute et vaslui jay qui s'est dit
que peut-être tu pourrais aller chez lui
plutôt que d'aller au restaurant pour
jouer à need for speed et pour qui lui
prépare un déjeuner lui même
oh là là le guet-apens malgré tout les
messages d'alerté qu'elle a pu voir elle
décide finalement qu'elle veut pas
gâcher son premier dan
elle préfère accepter ce qu'ils lui
proposent plutôt que de passer pour
quelqu'un d'impoli qui dit non
d'ailleurs c'est là on voit que les
choses ont beaucoup changé en dix ans la
plupart des filles ont compris qu'ils
n'avaient aucun mal à dire non cotées
pas impoli quand tu dis non bref il
arrive donc dans la maison émirats voit
qu'il ya personne dans la maison à part
l ecal pourtant qu'elle lui avait dit
que c'était la maison de sa famille dont
qu'elle s'attendait à ce qui est
peut-être ses parents ou un frère ou une
soeur de plus la maison elle est peu
meublé elle est un peu négligé ce que
mira ne comprends pas trop puisque c'est
censé être une maison dans lequel vit
une famille et normalement ça ressemble
pas à 5n s'assoit sur son lit et
surprise il y passe la manette qu'elle
se lève et comme promis il lui fait un
déjeuner ils préparent des sandwichs
mairesse dit alors [ __ ] merde en fait
je suis complètement parano l'approché
psycho cela depuis depuis le début et
malheureusement au moment où elles se
disent à ken s'assoit derrière elle et
il fait ce truc horrible et très cliché
y prend ses mains qui sont sur la
manette et il lui montre comment faire
pour bien gérer la manette bien appuyer
sur les boutons et bouger les joystick
ce qui est vraiment bizarre puisque
autant tu peux faire ce truc horrible de
chârost pour apprendre à faire un truc
très technique genre du golfe ou
apprendre à bien orienté une raquette de
tennis où j'en sais rien mais tu fais
pas ça pour apprendre à utiliser une
manette là c'est le truc
de trop donc mira se lève et dit à ken
écoute je dois y aller j'ai un devoir à
rendre il faut que je bosse merci au
revoir
ken ramène bel et bien meira à
l'université et y'a rien d'autre de
chelou à signaler ce jour là mira est là
clairement pas passer un bon moment et
du coup elle décide de ne plus du tout
parler à ken normal et puis un jour vers
23 heures qu'elle lui envoie un message
qui la rend furax sur un mécène
j'aimerais qu'on se voit soir je
t'envoie un taxi et tu viens chez moi
mira elle est énervée diouf et lui dit
mec pour qui tu me prends à quel moment
tu te dis que j'ai envie qu'on se revoie
et que j'ai envie d'aller chez toi et à
sa canne va juste répondre non non mais
pas de sexe promis j'ai juste envie
qu'on se voie pas de sexe promis cette
phrase c'est le next le plus total
à partir de là pendant des mois qu'elle
va continuer d'envoyer des messages
amira elle va continuer de les ignorer
et puis un jour ça s'arrête plus aucune
nouvelle de kent
mira explique qu'elle aurait aimé que
l'histoire se termine là sauf que nous
en avril mira et ses parents décident de
rejoindre une personne un peu éloignés
de leur famille mais qui fait partie de
la famille qui s'appelle âme et anne
elle vit aux caraïbes pendant six jours
aux caraïbes
anne valeur raconter son dernier voyage
en inde au cours duquel elle a rencontré
une femme locale riche qui est
rapidement devenue une amie très proche
d'elle on va l'appeler coni elle restait
constamment avec mira elle insisté tout
le temps en disant qu'elle connaissait
une école superbe qui offraient de très
belles opportunités et qu'elle voulait
vraiment que mira l'intègre sauf que
cette école
elle n'était pas aux us elle avait aussi
demandé à mira si elle était toujours
vierge et elle lui disait de se
préserver pour son futur mari quoi tu es
qui connut en fait en gros mira et ses
parents se sont fait embrigadés dans ce
qui s'apparente à une secte et coni a
réussi à leur faire lâcher
cent mille dollars quand tu te fais
embrigadés dans une secte c'est un
bourbier énorme
les techniques qu'ils utilisent ces
terrifiants et c'est terriblement
efficace le temps passe muraille ses
parents se rendent compte que kony n'est
pas celle qu'elle prétend être et la
confronte et connie disparaît du jour au
lendemain de leur vie et là vous vous
dites mais c'est quoi le rapport avec
ken la lucas je comprends pas et ya un
rapport un bien plus grand rapport qu'on
ne l'imaginait elle réalise qu'en fait
ken fait partie de ce [ __ ] de complot
et elle réalise qu'elle a évité le pire
elle a réalisé que kony travail et
probablement pour une organisation
criminelle de trafic d'humains
souvenez-vous kane avait dit amir a pas
de sexe je te le promets coni n'arrêtais
pas d'y revenir à 2
des vierges et de se préserver pour son
futur mari en fait depuis le début
qu'elle ne voulait pas du tout sortir
avec mira ou avoir des rapports sexuels
avec elle
il voulait juste éloigner tous les
hommes qui avaient autour de mira et
l'empêcher d'avoir un petit ami
mais peut-être que dans ce trafic
d'humains il était question de filles
vierges
bref horrible c'est horrible alors là là
on se dit mais [ __ ] mais pourquoi ils
sont pas les voir la police et hyper
grave
le problème c'est qu'ils ont aucune
preuve de tout ça c'est à dire qu'on
soit kony et ken hill ont jamais rien
fait d'illégal et que quand ils ont
donné de l'argent ni rsa famille c'était
de bonne volonté elle a quand même
essayé de retrouver des infos sur ken de
par son numéro de téléphone de par son
adresse msn etc
mais elle n'a rien trouvé mais explique
donc qu'elle n'avait jamais parlé de
cette histoire en disant parce que c'est
un vrai drame familial qu'elle a vécu
mais finalement en traînant sur lesdites
elle s'est dit bon j'ai peut-être enfin
raconter cette histoire parce que ça
peut aider des gens je montrais aux plus
jeunes qu'il faut pas faire confiance à
des inconnus que même quand on croit
tous croire sur quelqu'un on peut avoir
de très mauvaises surprises et s'est
trompé et que donc il faut toujours
faire des recherches approfondies sur
les gens pour être sûr qu'ils n'ont pas
un jardin secret très malsain comme par
exemple qui ne sont pas membres d'une
organisation qui fait du trafic
d'humains bref voilà c'était l'histoire
de mira très différent de toutes les
histoires qu'on a raconté je sais pas si
vous étiez dedans j'ai trouvé ça
incroyable on a vraiment un témoignage
de quelqu'un qui sait retrouve embrigadé
dans une secte et qui a réussi à s'en
sortir avant d'atteindre le point de non
retour et c'est toujours des témoignages
très intéressant et très enrichissant
parce qu'en fait tu peux te dire ça
arrive à n'importe qui c'est un truc de
ouf et encore plus aux gens qui
traversent et c'est le cas tous dans la
vie une phase un peu de faiblesse de
vulnérabilité de doute et ben euh ils
arrivent et ils profitent de cette
vulnérabilité de cette phase de doute là
pour te plombé le cerveau quoi c'est
terrible bref troisième histoire très
courte c'est celle de comme il est très
jeune et raconte quelque chose qui lui
arrive et quand il avait 4 5 ans un
dimanche de pâques à pâques
toute la famille de com se réunit chez
la grand-mère pour célébrer les vacances
les anniversaires pour se voir et c'est
comme et sa maman prennent donc la route
pour aller chez la grand-mère
après 40 minutes de route la voiture
manque d'essence et la maman de comme
décide de s'arrêter à une station
service pour faire un plat c'était une
vieille station service très rustique
avec une poignée de clients dans le
magasin bref une station-service rien
d'anormal du tout la merde comme lui a
toujours dit de ne pas parler aux
étrangers et aussi quand il reste seul
dans la voiture de ne pas ouvrir la
porte aux inconnus sa mère fait le plein
de la voiture elle a assez confiance en
comme pour aller payer sans le prendre
sauf que ce jour là il fait
très chaud comme et sa maman avait donc
ouvert les fenêtres de la voiture pour
profiter un peu du vent plutôt que de
mettre la clé mme comé seul dans la
voiture et en regardant par la fenêtre
et voit un homme qui a entre 30 et 40
ans approché lui cet homme s'accroupit
et lui dit hey salut comment tu
t'appelles comme se souvient qu'il ne
doit pas parler aux inconnus et dis donc
à cet homme
ma mère m'a dit jamais parler aux
inconnus je peux pas vous parler l'homme
va alors lui dire ah bah dans ce cas on
peut être ami si tu veux je m'appelle
charlie est maintenant que tu le sais je
suis plus un étranger comme il ya 4 5
ans et du coup il se fait brain il se
dit pas c'est vrai si quelqu'un me donne
son nom c'est plus un étranger donc je
peux lui parler cool comme a donc une
discussion avec cet homme il se souvient
plus des détails souviens juste que le
gars lui avait dit qu'il avait un joli
panier de pâques et souvient que même
étant enfant à ce moment là il s'est mis
à avoir mal à l'estomac mais sans
comprendre pourquoi
et ça c'est dingue se dire que comme il
ya quatre cinq ans mais son corps lui
envoie le message du attention alerte il
ya un problème
et comme il ne comprend pas pourquoi son
il a mal au ventre soudainement c'est
dingue ce tome la maman de comme sort
alors du magasin après avoir payé le
plein d'essence et remarque
immédiatement qu'il ya un homme adossé à
la fenêtre de la voiture qui est en
train de parler à son fils elle
s'approche alors rapidement la voiture
pour lui demander ce qu'il en train de
[ __ ] et le gars se met à paniquer
saisi la poignée de la porte et la tire
très très fort à multiples reprises
avant de comprendre que les portières
sont verrouillées il va alors passer son
bras à travers la fenêtre qui est ouvert
et attraper comme par le poignet pour le
sortir de la voiture par la fenêtre
comme du coup a très peur il se débat
l'homme lâche comme et part en courant à
pleine vitesse pour prendre la fuite
la maman de comme s'approche de la
voiture comme déverrouiller les
portières elle le prend dans ses bras et
lui fait le plus gros câlin de sa vie et
tous les deux savent à ce moment là que
comme vient d'être victime d'une
tentative de kidnapping qui heureusement
a échoué voilà les kidnappings c'est
horrible on sait que ça existe on sait
qu'il y en a tous les ans et c'est
triste et malheureux mais on s'imagine
pas que y'en a qui sont d'une telle
violence en fait bon eh bien écoutez
c'est la fin de ce serait d'horreur je
sais pas si on a eu deux ou trois
histoires parce que peut-être la
deuxième était très très longue et du
coup clément n'a pas jugé nécessaire de
mettre la 3e bon j'espère que l'histoire
vous ont plu le gars sur le palier c'est
ma [ __ ] d'anti benjamines ringer mois
devant chez moi j'ai trop peur j'ai je
vous l'avais déjà dit mais j'ai vraiment
mis le ring parce que maintenant je me
chie dessus à cause des threads et pas
parce que c'est moi qui les racontent
que j'ai pas peur bordel bref prenez
soin de vous soyez toujours vigilant des
inconnus c'est la base
faut pas devenir parano mais faut quand
même faire confiance à ses instincts
vraiment et puis voilà merci me regarder
le thread dormait
non mais vraiment bien
[Musique]